نتابع الان التطورات مع مراسلنا من مستشفى
ناصر في خان يونس مؤمن الشرافي مؤمن اهلا
بك اذا في ظل استمرار القصف وصعوبه الوصول
الى العالقين تحت الانقاض كيف يعمل السكان
والاهالي على انتشال ذويهم الشهداء
لدفنهم نعم مريم قبل ان نتحدث عن الجانب
الميداني والاوضاع
في غزه ورد بيان قبل قليل من هيئه المعابر
الفلسطينيه ينفي وجود اي تحركات اسرائيليه
يقول البيان ان الجانب المصري نفى للجانب
الفلسطيني في معبر رفح وجود اي معلومات
لدى الجانب المصري عن نيه الجيش
الاسرائيلي التحرك في محور الحدود
الفلسطينيه المصريه ويقول البيان ان كل
المعلومات الميدانيه عن تحركات لجيش
الاحتلال على الحدود مع مصر انطلاقا من
معبر كرم ابو سالم هي معلومات غير ير
صحيحه بحسب بيان هيئه المعابر الفلسطينيه
الذي صدر قبل قليل شهد محيط معبر كرم ابو
سالم منذ ساعات الصباح توغلا محدودا جدا
لعدد من الاليات والدبابات العسكريه
الاسرائيليه وسط قصف مدفعي وهناك انباء
قبل قليل وردت عن انسحاب هذه الاليات الى
داخل السياج الامني بعد اشتباكات دارت مع
المقاومه الفلسطينيه في هذه النقطه وحيث
قالت سراء القدس انها استهدفت الاليات
المتوغلة
محدود قرب معبر كرم ابو سالم بقذائف الهون
الحدث الابرز ميدانيا هي اشتعال محاور
الاشتباك سواء هنا في شرق خان يونس او
المحور الشمالي من مدينه خان يونس وايضا
في وسط القطاع في منطقه جحر الديك وال
المغرقه في منطقه جحر الدك تحديدا كتائب
الشهيد عز الدين القسام اعلنت قبل قليل
انها اوقعت قوه اسرائيليه اللي مكونه من
اربع جيبات عسكريه لقياده جيش الاحتلال في
كمين محكم وانها فجرت عبوات مضاده للدروع
والافراد في هذه الاليات والقوه
الاسرائيليه ثم هرعت الى المكان دبابه
اسرائيليه استهدفتها بقذيفه من نوع
الياسيم وايضا هرعت تقول بيان قسام ان سيا
انها استهدفت القوه النجده والانقاذ التي
جاءت لهذه القوه بعدد من الصواريخ وايضا
قذائف الهام وقالت ان سيار شاهدت سيارات
اسعاف وطائرات تنقل القت
نتيجه هذا الكمين الذي نصبته كتائب القسام
لقوه اسرائيليه مكونه من اربع جبات عسكريه
بالاضافه الى انه قبل قليل قسام اعلن عن
استهداف جنديين اسرائيليين في شرق خان
يونس بقذائف الار بيجي وقالت ان هذه
العمليه اسفرت عن مقتل الجنديين ايضا هناك
اشتباكات تدور في منطقه الزنه سرايا القدس
الجناح العسكري لحركه الجهاد الاسلامي
قالت انها استهدفت مقر قياده ميدان
بقذائف الهاون على الصعيد الانساني تتواصل
الغارات الاسرائيليه نتحدث خلال الساعات
القليله الماضيه عن خمس منازل دمرتها
طائرات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي على رؤوس
ساكنيها في مخيم المغازي وايضا في مخيم
دير البلح ومخيم النصيرات ومنطقه المغرقه
كل هذه الغارات اسفرت عن سقوط عدد من
الشهداء وعشرات الجرحى بينهم اطفال ونساء
نقلوا الى مستشفى شهداء الاقصى في وسط
القطاع ايضا قبل قليل سمعنا هنا في
خانيونس غاره اسرائيليه بصاروخ لم نعرف
نعرف حتى هذه اللحظه طبيعه الهدف الذي
استهدفته الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه في
المدينه وايضا في منطقه بلده عبسان
الكبيره كانت هناك غاره استهدفت مجموعه من
الفلسطينيين ادت الى استشهاد عدد منهم
وجرحي اخرين نقل الى مستشفى غزه الاوروبي
لتلقي العلاج الاوضاع برمتها في المنطقه
الجنوبيه تحديدا ومنطقه جنوب الوادي التي
يدعي جيش الاحتلال انها امنه هي اوضاع
ماساويه جدا بعد اجبار جيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي منذ ساعات مساء امس وحتى هذه
اللحظه سكان مخيم البريج تقول انرو ان نحو
150 ال فلسطيني يعيشون داخل هذا المخيم
بينهم الاف من النازحين الذين اجبرتهم
قوات الاحتلال على النزوح من مدينه غزه
والمنطقه الشماليه اجبروا على اخلاء
المخيم باتجاه المنطقه الغربيه ومخيم
النصيرات وتقول ان الاوضاع ماساويه وصعبه
جدا حيث لا تتوفر اماكن لايواء هذا العدد
الكبير في المنطقه الوسطى الذين اجبروا
على النزوح من منازلهم او حتى من مدارس
الانرو التي كانت كمركز ايواء يحتمون بها
من القذائف والقصف الاسرائيلي الذي يستهدف
الجميع في القطاع من شماله الى جنوبه م
شكرا شكرا لك مؤمنه الشرافي مراسلنا من
مستشفى ناصر في خان يونس